I'll read you a few snippets of the
letter it is a very long letter indeed
but they say that paparazzi
photographers are going to increasingly
extreme lengths to observe a monitor
Prince George's movements and covertly
capture images of him to sell to the
handful of international media titles
still willing to pay for them it is of
course upsetting that such tactics
reminiscent as they are of past
surveillance by groups intent on doing
more than capturing images and being
deployed to profit from the image of a
two-year-old boy they go on to say that
in a heightened security environment
such tactics are a risk to all involved
the worry is that it will not always be
possible to quickly distinguish between
someone who's taking photos and someone
who's intending to do more immediate
harm they say it's clear that while
paparazzi are always keen to capture
images of any senior member of the royal
family Prince George's currently their
number one target and they say we've
made the decision to discuss these
issues now as the instance are becoming
more frequent and the tactics are more
alarming this line is very important
they say that a line has been crossed in
any further escalation in tactics would
represent a real risk to security and it
says all of this has left the Duke and
Duchess concerned about that ability to
provide a childhood for Prince George
and Princess Charlotte that's free from
harassment and surveillance they know
that almost all parents love to share
photos of their children and they
themselves enjoy doing so but they know
that every parent would object to any
one particularly strangers taking photos
of their children without permission now
speaking to Kensington Palace they said
to me last night that this really did
come to a head when last week someone
was caught as they described it they
rented a car a photographer they parked
in a discreet location outside a
children's play area already concealed
in darkened windows he then took the
added step of hanging sheets inside the
vehicle and hunt created a hide stopped
with food and drinks to get him through
a full day of surveillance waiting in
hope to capture images of Prince George
so that is why now they are putting out
this very strongly worded letter